anytime a police department can get you
know equipment for the department
they're gonna try to do that hi I'm
Nicholas B with reason TV and today
we're talking with Bernie Kerik he's the
former commissioner of the city of New
York and you also were the interim
Minister of the Interior of Iraq in 2003
and you were a nominee for a Department
of Homeland Security when your career
was rudely interrupted by a variety of
things in 2009 Carrick pled guilty to a
felony tax and false statement charges
and served time and that's actually what
we're talking about now is related to
that as clemency you're on a campaign to
talk about clemency and sentencing
reform why is that so important to you I
think it's mostly important because I
got to see things personal observations
of the US criminal justice system that I
was unaware of maybe I was unaware of it
maybe I didn't pay attention to it I was
naive in some ways but given my
background 35 years in the business I've
run two of the largest law enforcement
organizations in the country the NYPD in
New York City correction including
overseeing Rikers Island for six years I
then went to prison and was a target of
a federal investigation and realized
that the u.s. criminal justice system
has flaws and failures that I was in a
way around talking talk a little bit
about that I mean you in an interview
with Al Jazeera you said when you put
someone in prison because it was a
commercial fisherman who caught too many
fish or because someone enhanced their
income in a mortgage application to buy
their first home you met those people in
prison so is is the problem that we're
bringing too many people into prison or
is it that the sentences are too harsh
or is it it's both you know it's both
for one thing you know you take a you
take a commercial fisherman that catches
too many fish
technically it's a regulatory issue it's
you know you could find them you can
penalize them you could suspend their
license for a period of time there's a
number of things
you can do to that person without
destroying his life his family and his
career endlessly for the rest of their
life they are now a convicted felon and
I think that's the thing that people
don't understand they they don't realize
that a felony conviction technically is
a life sentence
you're also critical of nonviolent drug
offenders being put in prison one of the
things that a lot of conservatives a lot
of Republicans will say they're you know
that's it's a unicorn there's no such
thing as a nonviolent drug offender you
say you you've met these people people
who are put in jail for first-time
nonviolent drug offenders ten years for
kid who sells or buys or possesses five
grams of cocaine five grams is the
weight of three sugar packets from
Dunkin Donuts
and you're putting a kid away for ten
years a little bit more you know if say
a kid is involved in a second a third
party conspiracy in other words the
federal government targets a major bad
guy and down trickled down the line of
accountability or responsibility you get
some kid that buys 5 grams 10 grams in
that conspiracy and they they target him
as a part of the conspiracy well he gets
charged with the total weight of the
conspiracy he doesn't even know the
target of the investigation he has no
idea what is when he now gets charged
and convicted takes a plea for 10 years
for 15 years you put that kid in prison
for 10 or 15 years he gets no real
rehabilitation he has no real education
he has no discipline and respect and the
whole time he's in prison he's gotten an
education of institutionalization
stealing fighting Conny manipulating and
there's no way in your mind that prison
can be changed
or you know I mean it's the once you go
to prison you're gonna come out more of
a criminal well that's what it does it's
institutionalization so how important is
the drug war to the overall increase in
the incarceration rate in the United
States the drug wars it but well there's
there's two issues behind the drug war
one drugs kill people on two fronts they
ingest them they die or the violence as
a result of the drug war which is
probably more devastating we have laws
on the books that deal with those drugs
and it's illegal so the cops have have
to go out there and do their job I was a
drug agent for years I've lost friends
my colleagues that were killed as a
result my partner was shot I've been
involved in gun battles as a result
there are people that belong in prison
and some for long periods of time and I
put them there and I have no problem
with what I've done but when you take a
young man that has an addiction problem
or take a young man that possesses five
grams and you put him in prison for 5 or
10 15 years that that is not a benefit
to society do you think pot should be
legal my personal opinion is you know
I'm not into it I've never been into it
I don't agree with it and because of my
family history of addiction not me
personally but my mother my father my
sister I'm against anything that would
create but you're right when you're
recognizing that it's the black-market
Santis that actually drop oh I
understand I understand that and you
know listen some people have said to me
pots a victimless crime and 2001 in May
of 2001 there was a execution-style
shooting of five people in an apartment
above the Carnegie Deli in New York City
they were laid down on the floor they
were all shot behind the head and two of
them will actually lived it was over
marijuana it's not really a victimless
crime but that's I mean if if alcohol
was made illegal tomorrow you'd have
that same scenario playing out over lay
wood right so you would it's I mean
people generally on pottery I would even
argue on a lot of
other drugs it's not like they take the
drug and they become a hyperactive it's
the deal right the vibe Rises right and
you know for me I'm not into it I leave
that up to the legislators as long as
there's laws on the books the cops are
going to enforce them the problem with
that have them met with the marijuana
stuff now the legalization make up your
mind you're going to legalize it you're
not going to legalize it it's legal in
some states it's not legal in others and
regardless of what states it's legal in
the federal government has not legalized
it so it's a mixed message and people
are gonna be they're gonna lose their
freedoms they're gonna be arrested
they're gonna be convicted because
they're under the interpretation they
could possess it in one place when in
reality the feds can come in and lock
you up for it who are the toughest
people to convince about clemency or
about sentencing reform is it law and
order Republicans is it Liberal
Democrats how do you go about actually
starting that conversation from what
I've seen so far I think the law in
order Republicans historically have been
the you know the the guys that say the
men and women that say you know lock
them up and throw away the key I don't
think that they understand what that
does to society I don't think they
understand the collateral consequence of
that to society I really don't think
they understood the economic cost to
society and over the last two years
especially in the time that I've been
home and talking about this I think that
stuff is coming more to light when you
have a state like Texas for example the
law-and-order capital of America now
looking at sentencing reform and
criminal justice reform and closing
prisons alternatives to incarceration
things like that and they're being very
sick to their putting together some very
successful programs well then they think
it's time for the rest of the country to
look as well can we talk a bit about the
militarization of police this is
something that reason has covered a lot
over the past you know a couple of
decades and certainly over the past 30
or 40 years over the course of your
career probably you know your your
policing life went from not really
dealing with SWAT teams to now every it
seems like every small town in America
has some kind of armored vehicle you
know there are thousands of SWAT raids a
year how do you feel about the
militarization of police and is it
causing problems like we're seeing in
places like Ferguson Missouri or even in
New York City with cases we hear a call
here's what's happened we especially as
a result of 9/11 in the aftermath of
9/11 in in the the realm of terrorism
that we face today in this country
naturally the police departments have to
be able they have to have the ability to
respond I completely disagree with the
militarization of all these smaller
agencies manok I live in a town in New
Jersey as maybe 35 40 policemen but
there are a talent there are 70
municipalities in my County where I live
there are municipal police departments
of 10 12 guys or men and women and they
themselves they want heavy weapons they
want armored vehicles they want what is
what is driving that you know desire by
police departments to get kind of
roided-up is it I mean it's a TV is it
free is it free gear from the federal
government well I mean a look at it
anytime a police department can get you
know equipment for the department
they're gonna try to do that I don't
have a problem with the department's
training i enhanced training specialized
training but when you create this
militarization of all these smaller
agencies and they don't have the ability
to communicate with each other and they
don't communicate with each other and I
seen this in my own County that's gonna
create a problem now if that being said
I am totally supportive of the larger
agencies you know having as much
Emergency Special Operations equipment
training and resources that they need
because you know my son for example is a
cop in Newark New Jersey he is on the
Newark SWAT team but these guys are
activated four or five six times a week
it newark is a bad town there are places
like that that
that type of response New York City it's
the unfortunately it's been the terror
target of you know al-qaeda and the
radical Islam for the last twenty years
you need that capability
we need the capability but in places
where you have these smaller towns it
could be as hurtful as helpful let's
talk a little bit about New York under
Rudy Giuliani and it continued under
Michael Bloomberg and actually I guess
it started under David Dinkins there was
a radical decline in crime and violent
crime in New York you know most of the
supporters of Bloomberg and of Giuliani
lay you know say it's the community
policing or you know kind of broken
windows theory
what what what explained the court you
know the crime drop in New York and also
what explained the more broad-based
crime but a violent crime declined
throughout America in the 90s it really
the crime decline started with Bill
Bratton who today is the police
commissioner of New York City back in
1994 Rudy Giuliani appointed him in New
York City as the police commissioner
then he created constant and ComStat was
an accountability process where as a
police commissioner I would get to see
the actual crime rates of the city on a
daily basis I didn't look at them
quarterly I didn't look at them by
annually or annually I looked at them
every single day when I got in my
vehicle at six o'clock in the morning I
had a folder on the seat next to me that
talked about all the crime stats through
the prior night if there's a crime spike
you know what immediately you can deploy
resources so the idea behind that is you
know there's a hot spot where suddenly
for whatever reason there's there's a
lot of criminal activity you flood that
zone in mediums immediately with cops
with resources with communities
relations with you know go into the
communities interaction with the
communities and you address it
immediately it's it's instant doing that
you see an immediate reduction in crime
and it's not just the crime get
it goes elsewhere it actually seems to
act to like minimize the amount of crime
what you're staying on top of it you're
staying on top of it and it's active its
real-time enforcement versus after the
fact following trends what what do you
think explains in place cities like San
Diego for instance had a steeper decline
in crime than New York it did not use
kind of the community policing or the
concepts of what do you think was going
on in the 90s because through about the
middle point of the 90s all the criminal
just was predicting the rise of super
predators etc and then pretty much
everywhere across the country crime
rates just collapsed well you can't say
I mean New York City I have a pretty
good idea of what we did because I was
there and what we did with regard to
crime reduction in the City Police
Department and in the city of New York I
did on Rikers Island this same kind of
oversight let's talk a little bit about
that because you as the head of
Corrections you ever saw a place like
Rikers Island which is you know infamous
for violence among inmates it was when
you oversaw a stark steep decline in the
amount of the criminal and criminal or
an inmate on inmate five riots what how
did you do that one the the same exact
method that the police department
honoring crime I started looking at
violence in the system and addressing it
daily increasing our searches holding
the inmates accountable for criminal
action you can't in a jail of prison you
cannot have it can't be a haven for
criminal activity and you know to give
you an example one of my first the most
violent incidents I saw it Rikers two
inmates held another inmate down on the
ground and carved lk4 Latin king into
his back with the chicken or a turkey
bone a hundred and eighty stitches when
I asked what happened to the inmate that
assaulted the inmates that assaulted
this kid he was put in special housing
was he charged with a crime no why my
house it's a jail that's what they do no
no you can't go into a prison facility
or a jail facility and attempt to murder
someone or cut them to pieces and think
that that's okay
so I started charging the
mates with violent crimes with
possession of deadly weapons the same
same thing that would be charged with on
the outside I also created an
accountability system to monitor monitor
staff assaults on inmates interaction
with inmates that kind of what happened
you know the New York Times just had a
report come out that particularly under
the last term of bloomer this was long
after you were involved in in New York
PD that actually the guards a lot of
interactions negative interactions with
inmates spiked up what do you think was
going on there here's what happens
whether it's a presidential
administration a state government or a
local government new people come in to
take over they ignore the policies that
worked they create their own and
whatever happens happens the leadership
and the accountability that was
instilled when I turned over the
department in 2000 completely went out
the window and as a result there has
been substantial increases in violence
on Rikers they have 10,000 less inmates
today than I had ten thousand yet their
violence is continually increasing there
were a number of corruption
investigations as a result of internal
things at Rikers the accountability and
leadership was shot and and I think that
was demonstrated in the New York Times
piece and more importantly over a
two-and-a-half year investigation that
the US Attorney's Office conducted and
and put out a report what do you make of
the the current case that's a super hot
of a abuse of power of police and in New
York the chokehold death of Eric garner
you've been critical of al Sharpton and
people like that or criticized the cops
but I mean what does it say that you're
putting a guy who's being charged with
selling loose cigarettes and a chokehold
is you know what has gone wrong with the
system
well here's here's the problem and I
think this is what a lot of people don't
understand whether the cops were
arresting the guy for selling cigarettes
or whether they were arresting him from
mass murder
once you tell someone is under arrest
and he resists you have to use whatever
force necessary to affect that arrest in
this case you have from what I saw in
the video and I think it was three guys
trying to arrest this guy - wait 380
pounds could it have been done
differently that's gonna be a for a
grand jury to decide the chokehold you
know is is something that in fact I
think it was Bill Bratton 20 years ago
that basically said you know you're
going against the policy if you use it
the problem you have is when you're
trying to take down somebody like that
that big that's strong you put them in a
submission hold at some point in time
you cut off their airway and it turns
into a chokehold here's here's my issue
with the whole thing it's people
shouldn't comment until the
investigations done I tried out not to
Monday Morning Quarterback anybody doing
the job that I know it's done because
I've done it my fear in arresting
somebody like a garner somebody that's
bigger than me some of these it could
overpower me is that they do overpower
me and they get my gun that's a fear
every cop has because if they get that
gun that's the best way though I mean
there's clearly among you know in not
just in New York and arguably less in
New York than in other cities there's
real tension particularly along racial
lines of you know black populations feel
like they're being overrun by the police
or they're being you know occupied by
the police what's the best way to you
know kind of deescalate that tension has
to be constant communication between the
police administration and the community
I had probably some of the best
community relations in the NYPD with the
community I was I was in the black
community
I had great relationships with the black
community you know it's the police
administrators have to realize this and
understand it the cops have to be fair
and respectful to the community it can
be done it's it's been done
unfortunately it's not done all
country and then you have problems what
do you what do you think about wearable
cameras and things like that I mean dash
cams have become you know kind of
routine
Wi-Fi actually I started the dash cams
in New York to the highway units and one
of the first incidents where I got to
prove to the Union who was adamantly
against it that it was to their benefit
was a woman made a sexual complaint
against a New York City Highway officer
was caught on camera
it was completely false and the camera
vindicated the cop so that's just
something like getting 90% of instances
with dash cams it ends up supporting the
police that's exactly right
you know especially because nobody's
having like a wearable camera for the
for instance the Michael Brown case in
Ferguson you know part of the problem is
that you've got a couple of witnesses
who say this is an unarmed guy in a 18
year old who was shot while his hands
were up in the air versus police saying
nothing right I mean what a wearable
well right here's here's the thing about
the police saying nothing whatever
happened is going to come out in an
investigation and from what I understand
now you have a local state and federal
authorities investigating it will
whatever happens gonna you know critical
public the wearable cameras you know I
don't personally me I think it hinders
the relationship between a cop and a
community because if I'm an aggressive
cop if I'm out there looking for
packages in New York City if you're a
new york city cop and you have a really
aggressive neighborhood that you have to
work i don't know if that's a benefit to
community relations because i'm not
talking to anybody
i'm not saying nothing i'm not gonna
have any interaction with any why why
not because anything you say is gonna be
interpreted by somebody that has no idea
what you're talking about
about what you mean you know if there's
a way to activate a camera when you go
into a combat situation or you go into a
confrontational situation there's a way
to do that maybe but just picture this i
put a camera on you for eight hours a
day and i'm gonna listen to everything
you say for eight hours
it's gonna be a matter of public record
because technically that's what's gonna
happen is that something you would want
does it invade your personal privacy of
course it does talk a little bit about
what it felt like you know your your
career was you know just the kind of
transcendent awkward arc upwards right
up into the moment when you were
nominated to be the the second secretary
of the department of homeland security
after Tom Ridge that's when all of your
problems started what did it feel like
to have you know just that type of world
start crumbling you know underneath your
feet there are no words to describe that
I had a 35 year career that was pretty
much unparalleled I had successes and
achievements in law enforcement that
nobody has matched in the country
especially where Rikers manok and then
to have the same government that I've
fought for and nearly died for more
times that I can count
target you you know initially over my
nanny
you know not paying tax on my my
children's nanny and there was a
undocumented immigrant right from Mexico
and did you know that she was
undocumented yeah do you think that
should be a crime personally yeah no no
I mean you know there are people in this
country really super super hard-working
people
this woman that worked for my wife and I
a loving caring treated my kids like
there were her own you know I'm
horrified that it happened but I loved
her to death and you know a good woman
and there are there are thousands out
there that do this you know I think
there's got to be a way to to fix that
in this immigration stuff regardless
when your entire world is then
scrutinized and and that's what happens
when you become the target of an
investigation like this it when it goes
from the nanny
to my apartment renovations and then to
everything your business your taxes your
anything in everything everything you
can't even imagine
every phone call anything you've ever
done is now scrutinized for the past ten
years it's overwhelming and I mean
obviously they dug up more than enough
to put you in jail do you think that
would happen to anybody I mean to go
back to your where we started you know
talking about clemency are talking about
sentencing reform are we living in a
world of you know one of reasons
contributors AB wrote a book called
three felonies a day which basically
said that everything has been
criminalized to a point where we're all
guilty of something every high school
student in America before they graduate
high school should be forced to read
silver glades book every high school
student because no one in America
understands and knows that if you give
me a stack of subpoenas the size of this
pack and give me the power to scrutinize
you as they did me I promise you you're
going to prison anybody in this room
anybody on that street anybody in
America can go to prison if you give me
subpoenas and give me the power to
investigate anyone all right well we
will leave it there that's a a happy
ending we've been talking with Bernie
Kerik he's the former commissioner of
New York City and he's the principal at
the carrot group now thanks for talking
with us
thank you sir a reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie